hey guys welcome to a special episode of
reasons to see where we give you special
reasons to see and not to see Ben
Affleck as Batman so let's hang out
haters okay guys in case you haven't
heard I don't know where you've been but
in case you haven't heard Ben Affleck is
a new Matt Damon I'm sure Ben Affleck is
the new Batman I am part of the one
percent of the world that is okay with
this actually I'm a huge Batman fan huge
Batman fan and I think the guys done
enough roles where he is capable of
doing this I think everyone who's in the
99 percent should start an occupied
Batman movement yeah there was a
petition there's an actual like petition
to Obama what not they took the petition
down but it was basically about Ben
Affleck should not be Batman oh I don't
know what happened you know like oh the
guy did suck for oh he did Google
hunting and then he sucks for many years
and then he became a director a lot of
things have changed like since
hollywoodland you know he wrote me this
Batman did Ben Affleck suck or did he
just pick crappy movies god it was seen
a lot of those move okay it was all he
was just a bad ideas a pretty horrible
but ya know like okay yes you did
daredevil okay it's his changed over the
years big [ __ ] whup daredevil yes
it's a shitty [ __ ] film okay I got it
but what was that like 15 [ __ ] years
ago you can't give the guy a chance he's
obviously grown over the years that is
true like all the goodwill he is built
with Khan may be gone the town Argo yeah
hollywoodland they would land that other
thing he just did like it's all gone
because he's Batman then he's solid now
look hollywoodland he played George
Reeves and George Reeves had to have the
super hero karizma and you know what he
he brought George Reeves to life
everyone can agree on that if you don't
agree on that you are part of the one
percent that does not like Ben Affleck
as George Reeves yeah hockey
hi George Reed mm-hmm his portrayal of
him was a guy who had a certain persona
but there was a real darkness inside of
the guy kind of like Bruce Wayne oh oh
and then he did the town and in the town
he plays a professional bank robbers so
Batman lives in a town with bank riding
yeah exactly we got there's another
correlation there could be a cool Jon
Hamm as Batman I mean a bad manager yeah
a lot of people were pitching of John
hang like I don't some other potentials
Jon Hamm is one I thought jon hamm would
have been really cool here's the case
though um it ain't gonna happen so I
also heard that we would we could have
seen Benedict Cumberbatch I don't know
if I would have liked that it seems like
a weird choice but he's just a really
good at yeah one of those guys are just
surprised yeah he's see he's the flip
side of that reaction because if they
had announced Oh Batman's Benedict
Cumberbatch every would be like what but
he's really good so I guess it'll be
okay he's actually good hell with Ben
Affleck right he did the town he was a
professional bank robber so he says gaya
as a secret identity in this dark world
but on the outside he's this really
charming really nice guy but the guys
also really lonely at the same time kind
of like Bruce Wayne also he did our ego
and in that role he was this guy you had
to be a hero for people where he had to
find himself and everything and he made
sacrifices in order to be a hero kinda
like the dark knight rises ah yeah so
when you look at some of the things that
Ben Affleck has done look I know he
didn't reindeer games oh also um his
real small ass role in boiler room who
is this like rich ass [ __ ] like
Bruce Wayne and he was a total badass in
that role like Bruce Wayne like Bruce
Wayne there's a lot of reasons why you
know you might do a good job I could
totally see why everyone's hating on him
though it at the same time but I think
he's being judged too much off its past
films because when I heard they were
gonna go with with Ben Affleck as Batman
my first reaction was also huh oh yeah
that was my reaction see because like
it's one of those things where I feel
like if you cast somebody who's that big
and sort of mainstream and she gets
distracting like I kind of like when
they can't christian bale as batman he
wasn't a household name yet so it was
cool because he could just be Bruce
Wayne for me so that's my main concern
with Ben Affleck is just I don't want to
be distracted by Beth yeah you don't
wanna be going this has been Affleck as
Batman yeah it's like huge stars plus
superhero movie is not always the best
combination but the thing is i flashed
back to things like Heath Ledger as the
Joker or even as I heard Michael
Keaton's Batman and I forgot what the
other examples are but they're even when
tons I know not everyone will put this
on the same level but even at hathaway
as catwoman she got really good reviews
for dirt by rises yeah and so there
we've had time and again it's like
people have selective memories because
everyone was like what Heath Ledger wise
like that guy from from 10 Things I Hate
About You oh yeah bro and it was great
and so I guess yeah it's a risk to take
but it's like wait and see what they're
gonna do because sometimes actors just
have a side you haven't seen yet yeah
and you know with Ben Affleck I'd rather
encouraged a guy you know we've already
locked in for a movie we've been waiting
for forever movie that features Batman
and Superman so might as well try to
give the guy some empowerment because I
don't want to see some shitty [ __ ]
ville yogurt and no like then the world
is hating on you it's gonna be a harder
job but I feel like in a way if a lot of
actors i know will take a lot of
whatever's going on and put that into
the role i feel like with all that kind
of a trick he's saying he could use that
to internalize a lot of pain and you
know a lot of the way people look at him
and he could I have a feeling that he's
gonna put it some of his best work into
this film he he made it come back with
him as a director he did he's doing a
great job as an actor I really think
he's gonna I I have hope for him
nothing's gonna be good hope for him
well also I mean I know Chris Nolan is
involved and and he again is good at
picking unlikely actors for roles but
also even though he is involved we don't
know exactly what their take on Batman
his second event of Steel you know yes
it's like for all you know that take on
him will be perfect
about athletes right oh I'm sure for not
idiots you know what I mean yeah I doubt
that they would go into this being like
I don't know pick somebody who the kids
like Ben Affleck yeah Ben Affleck kind
of makes sense because he is like
40-something I think 41 and I know
they're going for an older type of bat
manatees he's just famous enough you
know to to kind of have sort of that
Batman swagga SH type of image you know
going on yeah I think he can pull off
Bruce Wayne yes I believe he can plop
Bruce Wayne and I think the big concern
is can he pull off Batman and you know
can you eat tough tough got Batman but I
think it Batali pretty can be a
believable tough guy um I don't know
what kind of voice is good too was he
clean shaven in the town no you haven't
had a little bit of facial hair okay cuz
now cuz I associate good Ben Affleck
with beards now oh my god is hope Batman
has a beer that would be cool Batman had
a bearded man beard man no you know
what's gonna happen is gonna talk like
with a regular American accent uh uh
from for when he's Bruce Wayne and then
when he's bad when he's gonna have a
Boston accent that'd be cool yeah that'd
be [ __ ] yeah was joking you [ __ ]
[ __ ] there's really belligerent
blasted keeps keeps breaking a bank
robberies what's going on ha be dead you
got to [ __ ] faces you [ __ ] homo
all I know from Boston people are sort
of like the meanest [ __ ] people in
the world apparently according to whole
cinema yeah and if you want to be tough
you go there yeah now yeah [ __ ] New York
yeah I'm not going to pop yeah the
emergent is all like Broadway now so
easy so now we're going to go to Boston
and get really gritty you don't I'm glad
about to Ben Affleck he's American and
we're getting all this study I don't not
actually bother by the popular casting
all these like British people to play
American characters but it's kind of
cool to know that Batman is American
again yeah nice yeah doesn't really
affect me okay guys now that we're done
talking about that why don't you go
ahead and comment below and let us know
what you think about Ben Affleck being
Batman no no no don't I know what most
of us are gonna say Emily's don't you're
gonna break the comment well yeah but
you know we have to say why not how
about this if your not psyched about Ben
Affleck tell us who you want to see is
new Batman yeah Beatrice I wish you're
not going to get and once you're done
doing that come on over here check this
link out because when you click it
you're going to see more episodes of
reasons see and if you want to like us
on Facebook like us right here gonna
follow us on twitter follow us right
here and last but not least if you want
to get updated every time a new review
or a video is out like this one
subscribe yeah do it it's our first news
reports show over the drawer yes [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh god now it
just sounds like a like a weird
opportunity yeah Al Pacino as Batman
what would probably be the best banjo
pesci is Robin Jovi its rocket the two
shortest superheroes you've ever had but
Joe Pesci's still shorter so it works
out I'll fright I want eggs benedict
tonight cook it oh that would be offered
them who be Alfred Michael Foster I've
been so weird I was gonna say a Harvey
Keitel's / because that would be good
too Oh what is it people were talking
about philip seymour hoffman any pain it
would be a great pain waited really
tired penguin but yeah I know you'd be
great and Jim Carrey has the Riddler yes
just keep going that dough works out
full totally get a good bet they should
use like all the original Batman actors
and then play that put all them as
villains they should take the original
actors from the joel schumacher batman
movies and then put them in a a Nolan
esque Batman movie yeah and see how that
blend works it will be cool really dart
out also whimsical Arnold Schwarzenegger
has Commissioner Gordon that would be so
the bat signal huh get to the roof
that's the shyness tomorrow
you
you